the United States cannot kill its way
out of the war against Islamist terror
to turn the tide America must rethink
its strategy since the attacks on New
York and Washington on September 11th
2001 the United States has defined its
enemies as specific terror groups our
war on terror begins with al Qaeda but
it does not end there it will not end
until every terrorist group of global
reach has been found stopped and
defeated the Obama administration
defined Isis as enemy number one and its
control of mosul and raqqa as the
pressing problem we're going after ISIL
from their stronghold right in downtown
Raqqa to Libya where we took out Abu
Nabil the ISIL leader there
the point is ISIL leaders cannot hide
and our next message to them is simple
you are next Trump doubled down by
killing even more Isis numbers and
driving them out of there captured lands
we are effectively ridding the world of
Isis I see that as a primary role and
that's what we're going to do whether
it's in Iraq or in Libya or anywhere
else but while America's current
anti-isis campaign may severely degrade
them it will not defeat or destroy them
instead it may help al Qaeda assume the
lead in Syria and facilitate the rise of
the next Isis inclination in Iraq in
short the Cardinal error of American
foreign policy since 9/11 has been the
pursuit of specific named terror groups
as the enemy the US needs to rethink
that strategy by focusing US military
legal and policy tools on the
destruction of particular groups like
Isis and al Qaeda policymakers miss the
real enemy the Salafi jihadi movement to
understand the way forward we need to
understand this movement
let's be clear the root cause of
Islamist terror is not specific terror
groups like Isis and al-qaeda the cause
of terrorism isn't the religion of Islam
either it's not Muslims the roots of
Islamist terror sprout from Salafi jihad
is 'm a fringe sect with extremist
beliefs about the practice of Islam the
practice and observance of Sunni Islam
like all major contemporary religions
varies greatly on one end of the
spectrum are Sunni who are fundamentally
secular there are also devout mainstream
sunny salafism is a trend in Sunni Islam
and among Salafis the spectrum of belief
ranges from those who abstain from
politics and violence to those who
pursue political power to affect change
to those who justify violence for
political purposes positioned at the
extreme are those who seek to destroy
the state and establish a new polity
under Sharia though even these groups
disagree among themselves over when
where and against whom violent acts are
justified to achieve their aims Salafi
jihadi ideology brings together groups
and individuals into a network that
seeks the same shared outcome and these
groups and individuals comprise the
Salafi jihadi base it's these Salafi
jihadi groups that pose the threat of
terrorism al Qaeda and Isis most
prominent among them yet the majority of
Muslims reject the end state that al
Qaeda Isis and the broader Salafi jihadi
base pursue so how has Salafi jihadi ISM
a once isolated ideology becomes so
powerful in short vulnerable Sunni
Muslim populations have turned to Salafi
jihadi groups for help
Sunni populations across the Muslim
world are now under threat both real and
perceived from Iran Shia Muslims the
Assad regime Russia the Kurds and even
the West among others they're looking
for help to survive modern Salafi Jihad
ISM has been present in the Muslim world
for decades but at the edges of society
in stable countries Sunni populations
had no reason to tolerate extremism in
large numbers
but popular grievances beginning with
the Arab Spring in 2011 inspired
uprisings that then spread and spiraled
out of control disrupting the stability
of the Middle East there are now at
least six failed states in the Muslim
world weak states from Nigeria to Egypt
to Afghanistan are also unable to
deliver basic goods to their populations
in these destabilized countries the
Salafi jihadi base delivers protection
stability and assistance to these
threatened and aggrieved populations
Sunni communities are now making
short-term decisions to tolerate the
Salafi jihadi base ending the basis
decades in isolation
so if Isis and al-qaeda are taking
advantage of weak Sunni populations why
can't the United States just target the
leaders of these Salafi jihadi groups
and help partners recapture terrain well
Al Qaeda and Isis are the most dangerous
and prominent groups in the Salafi
jihadi movement attacking them does
nothing to weaken the Salafi jihadi
movement itself and doesn't actually
break the relationships that Salafi
jihadi groups have with vulnerable Sunni
populations US policy decisions
particularly those regarding Syria
aesthetic ground truth narrative that
the u.s. doesn't care about the Sunni or
worse it's actively supporting the
aggressors against the Sunni in fact the
United States has implicitly lied with
all actors fighting against Isis in
Syria except for the majority Sunni
opposition group the u.s. even has a de
facto partnership against Isis with the
Iranian and Russian backed Assad regime
which was compounded by President
Trump's decision to stop arming the
Sunni opposition group the u.s. remains
focused on disrupting or destroying the
cells of al Qaeda and Isis that are
plotting major operations against the
West reducing the military strength of
select groups especially through
regaining territory and killing group
leaders this does nothing but change
which group vulnerable Sunnis run to or
which leaders drive the Salafi jihadi
base Al Qaeda and Isis each seek to be
the leaders of the Salafi jihadi
movement imagine that these filings
represent the individuals and groups
that believe in the Salafi jihadi
ideology Al Qaeda was the only global
organization and like a magnet draws the
filings to it
so too did al-qaeda assume the
leadership position the rise of Isis
added another poll to the movement
al-qaeda's and Isis's competition didn't
weaken the movement both advanced it
defeating Isis will position al-qaeda to
capture the remnants of that
organization defeating al Qaeda -
weakens the movement but another
organization will rise in its place
while it is possible and may even be
necessary to target individuals or
networks guns and bombs cannot destroy a
movement the elements of American power
now operate against a mere fraction of
the movement they may destroy that
fraction but will not destroy or even
defeat the movement itself this is why
the United States must look beyond the
groups and focus on the Salafi jihadi
base itself so can we win knowing what
we know now what should we do to move
forward as a first step the United
States must work to resolve local wars
and conflicts that seemingly fall
outside of American interests but
actually strengthen the Salafi jihadi
base none of these wars have a military
solution resolving them will be no easy
task but an end to the conflicts would
help to demobilize sunnis and would
constrain the Salafi jihadi bases
ability to insinuate itself into Sunni
populations and generate support
additionally in areas penetrated by or
vulnerable to the Salafi jihadi base US
policies must promote accountable
governments that are legitimate
transparent and responsive to the needs
of citizens the only path to victory is
resolving local conflicts and societal
upheaval focusing on the Sunni
population and breaking the ties between
the people and the Salafi jihadi based
anything less ensures another generation
of Americans will be fighting the same
war and losing
to learn more about my take on what the
United States should do to defeat Al
Qaeda Isis and the Salafi jihadi
movement check out the link to my new
report America's real enemy in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you'd like AI scholars to
cover on rethink tank and be sure to
subscribe for more videos and research
from AEI